kendall Jenner rings in her 21st
birthday yeah I'm excited as kim
kardashian resurfaces on social media
just not on her own page kendall stepped
out in not one but two sexy ensembles
for her big night the model kicked off
the festivities in this mosaiced
jumpsuit for dinner at seafood joint
catch LA where she was joined by pals
including hailey Baldwin then at Kendall
slinked into this silver number to head
over to 1920s themed hotspot Delilah
[Applause]
inside she was joined by her whole
family ET can confirmed sister Kim
Kardashian was there but she didn't pop
up in any social media posts Wednesday
night she's still keeping a low profile
following that Paris robbery though Kim
did resurface on social media this week
posing for this new picture with the
late Alton sterling 16 year old son
Cameron at one of Kanye West's LA shows
but back to the party sisters Khloe
Kourtney and Kylie all partied the night
away in sexy looks of their own
[Music]
and then there was the big surprise
Kendall got a new car Chloe shared this
clip of the adorable reveal I'm super
excited
[Music]
you